yesterday
i told you about republican senator
lindsey graham
threatening riots if donald trump is
indicted
infowars conspiracy theorist alex jones
who by the way
really doesn't like me thank your lucky
stars every day you're not dave pagman i
know he doesn't like me alex jones is
now joining in with mega world in
predicting violence now as always
his predictions are more specific take a
listen to this
in the next 71 days we're going to see
some very violent fireworks
i would predict
racially motivated mass shootings
bombings
poisonings
we're gonna see poisonings and bombings
he says attacks on power supplies being
blamed on the right wing
they intend to bring in a full
dictatorship in the next 71 days who
will be the dictators and we are all
strapped to this thing
this is such a dangerous time and i
would advise the globalists
who are mid-level that think they're
about to have a leftist revolution i
like that mid-level globalists if you're
a high-level globalist or a low-level
globalist you don't have to worry
globalist
internationalist trotskyite socialist
shun like obama trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
yeah all right last few seconds
globalists don't actually plan at the
higher levels to have that they plan on
having a civil war that brings down
america and you'll be the fall guy right
very very scary stuff now i do wonder
if there's a donation maybe of 29.99 to
alex jones that might help stop the
globalists
i don't know is it more upsetting
honestly
is it more upsetting that alex jones
says this stuff
or is it more upsetting that some people
believe it or is it more upsetting that
some people believe it so much that then
they donate money as a result which of
those three things is the most
disturbing and this is very similar to
yesterday's segment on lindsey graham it
sounds to me
like alex jones
is predicting
that trumpists are going to do all these
things but he's incentivized to make it
look like they're not really trumpists
if they do it because remember he said
there's going to be bombings and there's
going to be poisonings and there's going
to be attacks on our uh water supplies
you know different what did he say power
sources
and it's going to be blamed on the right
he already is preemptively you know he
just got dinged almost 50 million
for
lies related to supposed false flags and
he's already out there doing his false
flag dog and pony show again it's quite
a wild situation but there's alex joins
joy alex jones joining in as many of you
know i'm a busy person i don't always
have the exact correct nutritional plan
for my meals every single day and that's
why i also take a multivitamin and a
couple of supplements but doing them all
separately can be a little bit time
consuming which is why athletic greens
is just fantastic and they're one of our
sponsors i've been using the athletic
greens since last year it just really
simplifies nutrition i just do a scoop
of the ag-1 and i'm getting 75 high
quality vitamins and minerals and my
probiotics and it's all from whole food
sources i drink it in the morning i know
i'm good i don't have to be messing
around with different pills and
supplements or whatever or spend time
planning when what time of day do i need
to take each one i just get it all with
one scoop you can put it in a smoothie
you can drink it straight it tastes
great and then i'm just good for the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below